déjà vu
nous regarder nous les stars de la
saison euh en fait je suis la chaîne
principale la 2 en fait
vous m'avez pas oublié il y a toujours
ces petites paires de chaussures elles
sont elles sont cessées votre signature
dites-moi tout
c'est ma signature le 14 juillet je
porte la bannière tricolore au pied mais
avec le coeur aussi avec le cœur aussi
et je les envisage peut-être un jour ses
chaussures il avait déjà eu l'impression
qu'il n'y avait rien à la télévision
bien sûr
on n'a jamais eu autant de contenu
autant d'écran et pourtant rien n'arrive
à capter notre attention
vous pensez pouvoir sauver la situation
[Applaudissements]
pour rénover un seul de ces chars il en
existe vous savez 225 exemplaires 200
vont être rénovés ça va prendre des
années le moteur est surpuissant
1500 chevaux on est en train de leur
imposer un rythme ils sont là derrière
je les vois ils ont la langue pendu son
aide arrêtez-vous arrêtez-vous vous avez
trop envie que les Bleus je peux dire
qu'on a pas accéléré encore c'est le
char au monde qui accélère le plus vite
[Musique]
6500 personnes ont défilé sur les
Champs-Élysées ce matin sous les yeux
d'Emmanuel Macron et de son invité
d'honneur le Premier ministre indien
bien sûr Paris est la plus belle ville
du monde mais trop de papier sur les
choses c'est trop de tâches sur les murs
trop de négligence qui rend les vis le
visage de pain
hier le Premier ministre indien contesté
par des ONG pour ses dérives
anti-démocratiques a donné son accord
pour l'achat de 26 nouveaux appareils et
trois sous-marins les Parisiens vont
faire la connaissance d'une voiture
blanche et blanche c'est son nom leur
rappellera la période devoir de soigner
leur capital leurs auteurs recevront la
palme d'horreur monsieur maudit dont on
a appris ce matin qu'il avait été fait
par le Président de la République
grand-croix de la Légion d'Honneur
distinction extrêmement importante et
marque de de confiance également sur les
Champs-Élysées ces drapeaux des
spectateurs indiens heureux d'être
imagine que cette amitié franco-indienne
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui qui
veut dire quelque chose pour vous oui
les les femmes s'expriment plus que que
les hommes on est un des rares pays
démocratiques à avoir un défilé
militaire comme celui-là absolument oui
évidemment les défilés sur la Place
Rouge place
et il y a chaque année en Inde une
parade le jour de la République indienne
en janvier à laquelle d'ailleurs la
France est régulièrement invitée depuis
5 5 années la France est invitée
d'honneur en Inde pour cette parade le
budget de l'armée grosso modo pour les
années qui viennent a été validé 400
milliards un peu plus de 400 milliards
d'euros pour 6 ans c'est ça
tout à fait c'est une somme considérable
qui correspond à l'évolution des risques
qui sont identifiés par le Président de
la République par le chef d'état-major
des armées mais sur de l'huile c'est une
très mauvaise idée et vous allez voir
pourquoi je verse l'équivalent d'un
verre d'eau
vous voyez c'est très impressionnant
heureusement que j'ai cette combinaison
de pompiers plutôt dans la matinée le
chef de l'État lui a reçu un accueil
plus mitigé de la foule
mais je sais pas si on entend quelques
clameurs qui viennent du public ou
quelques hués les gens qui se sont sur
place ne le diront
et je suis maintenant aux côtés de Paris
c'est une tradition chez reine de se
retrouver pour ce concert de Paris
depuis 10 ans qu'est-ce que vous inspire
justement ce dixième anniversaire je
suis heureuse heureuse que ce
rendez-vous soit devenu un rendez-vous
pour toute la France et qui rayonne dans
le monde entier et remonter pour prendre
une bonne impulsion pour attraper
l'accord
[Musique]
et c'est aussi une façon de se retrouver
dans ce lieu magique unique à un an des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques et
justement merci Madame la mère justement
Tony estanguay c'est vrai que dans un an
le 26 juillet est très exactement et
bien on va vivre un autre moment
historique oh là là mais aurore est
reparti
il faut augmenter les salaires il faut
les mettre à 1600 1800 vous entendez je
des chiffres mais les les uns les plus
les autres techniquement parlant et
économiquement parlant ce n'est pas
faisable ce n'est pas possible tout
simplement maintenant maintenant
de loyer il est plus cher que le SMIC en
plus quoi donc
les parasols Jean-Claude et sa femme
Béatrice descente au Portugal avec un
couple d'amis Jacques et Annie combien
il faut que vous décharger
[Applaudissements]
tu fais ton plein de gasoil 200 kg de
viande ça y est aucun d'entre vous ne
peut vivre avec le SMIC et vous faites
des injonctions
que j'ai acheté une voiture tu faisais
un crédit tu partais en vacances
aujourd'hui le quai aujourd'hui parce
que ça fonctionne
parce que ça me contrarie excusez-moi
excusez-moi tout le monde ça me
contrarie parce que il y a des gens le
15 du mois ils sont déjà à découvert
avec le SMIC exactement on va remercier
qui joue à tous tes pilon
c'est non franchement c'est non moi je
veux carrément
de hauteur là d'accord mais là un
chargement propre qui dérange pas ça
fait 17 ans que je voulais mon camion ça
fait 17 ans que je voulais faire la même
chose je n'ai jamais été embêté comme ça
je suis écœuré franchement je suis
écœuré ça donne envie d'arrêter le
camping-car tout de suite les chercheurs
ont suivi 54 salariés pendant 23 jours
de vacances donc un peu plus de 3
semaines verdict c'est au bout du 8e
jour qu'intervient le pic de bien-être
ah au bout de 8 jours que vous retrouvez
une certaine forme mais ensuite eh ben
c'est là chute libre dès le 11e jour
c'est l'ennui qui pointe le bouton les
vacanciers ressentent un mal du pays en
tout cas la maison leur manque leurs
habitudes du quotidien certains auraient
même hâte de retrouver le
boulot jour
Sporting box advis in the moon what what
distribuer à plusieurs écoles du
district cette BD conseil ne panique pas
cache-toi comme l'ourson jusqu'à ce que
la police arrive si l'enfant est
découvert il doit courir comme un lapin
enfin un dernier recommandation si on ne
peut pas s'enfuir on doit se battre de
toutes nos forces pour la mission
accomplie merci à tous on va on va
retourner au fort on a faim non alors on
y va salut